[Music]
city bus and transit riders got a
lifeline in the latest pandemic related
relief bill
new york city's subway system will get
billions though much less than it asks
for
don't think of this as a bailout to the
profligate the aid begins to correct
for an historic inequity the federal
government has long been subsidizing our
least deficient systems
in rural and small town america and
neglecting cities
transit aid in a time of crisis should
not reward cities for decades of fiscal
mismanagement
but should help them get past covet and
chart a path to stability
new york's is the most used public
transit system in the u.s
and typically does not rely on any
federal health to run the system
now compare it to oneida in upstate new
york currently the big apple has lost
most of its subway riders and fares
congress filling that gap
is necessary and timely less cities be
robbed of the ability
to rebound any post-pandemic aid should
require that they economize
but when it comes to transit cities
should no longer be
disfavored do you think big cities
should get more federal transit aid let
us know in our poll
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to like and
subscribe
for more research and videos from aei